well there is a discussion underway that
could lead to several military bases
closing as part of a cost-saving measure
Nevada has four military sites including
Nellis Air Force Base and the last time
the base realignment and closure
commission or BRAC met was 17 years ago
with Nellis Air Force Base potentially
in the crosshairs eight news now
reporter Joshua peguero spoke to the
installation Commander
during the last Brad commission done in
2005 Nellis Air Force Base actually
benefited gaining 1400 military and
civilian personnel
lawmakers Lobby Brack to protect bases
in their districts from closing citing
the economic impact in their communities
Colonel Joshua demott's installation
Commander at Nellis says Nellis is vital
to the military the only conversations
that I've had in my 16 months here is
only how we can bring more to Nellis not
take anything away he as that leadership
isn't planning for a black review but a
powerful lawmaker Democrat Betty
McCollum chairwoman of the House
Appropriations Committee openly
supported a BRAC review back in May the
department has stated in recent years
that it has nearly 20 percent access
infrastructure and we pay for that
infrastructure to be maintained there
have been five bracks since 1988 with
the 2005 one being considered the most
complex and expensive it led to 24 major
bases closing 24 bases getting realigned
and 12 000 civilian jobs being
eliminated for the combat Air Forces
what we like to say here at Nellis is
asgos analysis so goes the Air Force the
Department of Defense has yet to
announce whether it's planning to ask
Congress to authorize a brag review
reporting at Nellis Air Force Base Josh
peguero 8 News Now